ouais ouais ouais ouais
[Musique]
arrête-toi fait la paix la fête la bcc
richard est rouge
[Musique]
oui oui ça va faire des résultats
allez bon titulaire chico les gypsies
d'imhoff là on avait fait
[Musique]
[Rires]
par de papouasie
[Musique]
merci
des malades ont construit père jolie de
la 90e retient qui me fascine sourire
idiot mais il faut qu'ils changent pas
allez je ne peux pas proposer à paris
par ailleurs mais je sais pas ce qui m'a
fait me fallait pas faire elle était bon
il n'y avait rien rallye voilà on fait
d'autres et d'autres trucs avance que
ont été déchargés du parisien des actes
non messieurs
lâchez-moi agression qu'est ce que tu
veux qu'est ce que tu veux faire autre
chose que tu sois star mais celle des
pasta sheridan et n'oubliez pas je veux
attachés et un chauffeur
je t'ai pas de cheveux attachés à ce que
j'attends voilà six mois six mois tu me
fais pas confiance mais bon on arrête
tout j'imagine que la prime
imaginez votre lampe rail cambuston
price a fait un petit finir ta famille
aussi super c'est pas toi
non soyons honnête j'ai fait à mon cap
et le groupe avait notamment
[Musique]